it is time
for you say to play
i don't know if my
sense of time has warped this year but
it feels like it's been a while since
the last date of play i could be
completely wrong it feels like it's been
a minute um i'm excited i believe this
one is mostly focusing on psvr 2 from
what i have heard which i have had the
chance to try but i'm actually not
allowed to tell you about so but forget
i said that um
we got 14 seconds to go let's jump in
um i'd love to see the bloodborne pc
announcement
i don't think it's happening
it's not gonna happen everybody temp
your expectations yeah mostly expecting
to see some some vr games here so
let's go
they always start with great music i
feel like uh
i should have played the whole 14
minutes just so we could chill out
i'm excited
it really feels like june
starting with the data's ballsy this has
got to be a game that we know
you don't start with a date unless it's
a game that we know
[Music]
resident evil
[Music]
it's resident evil 4
the music
[Music]
it's resident evil
oh my god i've been hoping for this for
so long
where is he before remake
dude i want to see what it looks like
one of the best games ever made
oh my god that looks so good
i guess you me
i beat the wrong spot to vacation eh
hell yeah it's gonna be funny going
from
rea to reform our most sacred body
it begins
now
dude i'm so excited it was kind of
inevitable right but i was still
very very very very very hotly
anticipating
resident before we make that is awesome
what was the date now what happened that
night
the pain
even for a second
this time oh yeah and this is in vr it
can be different
it has to
that first time you enter the village
and have to stay alive for as long as
you can march 24.
yes dude yes
i will do a full playthrough of that on
the channel
ooh
the uh oculus or rift game sorry quest
game is awesome i tried to do a full
playthrough but i had to we've got to
delete great playstation updates the
game to make room um and i didn't
realize it deleted my save so with
resident evil 4 coming to ps4
playstation vrt
to see it now let's get a sneak peek at
four games in development for
playstation v starting with village oh
my god
okay
now
let's take a look at him
[Music]
wow well ethan winters
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
yes mother
yes
the whole game
i really liked r8 i had a great time
with it
that first house especially lived in the
press houses was awesome
again as i was saying earlier so clearly
inspired by re4
that
playing those two back to back for me at
least like the most recently that i
played
[Music]
might feel a little bit weird
[Music]
it'll be awesome
again the the quest excuse me the quest
game has been
super cool
you
of all people have the audacity to
question me
you
who emerged from the future waters of
the vine
to plunder our righteous gains and cut
our throats like a demon in the night
what have you done to ensure the future
of this forsaken city
you it
[Music]
it was i who shined as a beacon of hope
for all
the tower cries out for blood
and i vow to spell it
[Music]
when the bells ring the song they sing
will be righteous
oh it's walking dead oh i was completely
wrong tourist cool
completely wrong
[Music]
nomanski
[Music]
i wonder how motion sick i would get
playing no man's sky
[Music]
surely it's pretty bad
it's gonna be a challenging
[Music]
i love no man's sky these days
yeah i really didn't like it at lunch
love it now
i've played this this is why i've tried
uh psvr2 i've played it
hey i'm technically not allowed to talk
about it i asked you a question
everyone says reyes is a good shot i
guess all i will say is that i found it
very very
it's a snap
we're not gonna make
it it's a snap mom
[Music]
i was actually just very impressed with
that
ps4 in general
but redemption is huge playstation take
my body with green assault bias and all
that
may mean absolutely nothing but i was
super impressed i found it very cool
find out why the machines are attacking
[Applause]
boss fight
do that
and you shall be a free man
it will take all your wits
your skills
and courage
you have walked in the shadows reyes
now it is time unfortunately i basically
can't comment on this at all the light
gorilla is great on to the next
hi i'm ben mccabe narrative director at
gorilla
i hope you enjoyed your first look at
horizon call of the mountain coming
exclusively to playstation vr2 we're
also happy to announce that a big update
to horizon forbidden west including new
game plus will be available to download
on playstation 4 and playstation 5 today
cool
it's actually a very good time for me to
get back into that game i've been like
so swamped
[Music]
under new releases and that's finally
kind of died down now
verizon was very early on my list of
games to go back to
ultra hard difficulty damn we don't know
what that's like
for details on this free update please
check out playstation blog
all of us at gorilla thank you for your
continued support and please stay tuned
for more updates to come awesome
get ready a playstation fan favorite is
coming to pc
it's not gonna be blood one it's not
going to be blood but
there's no way you drop out like that
there's no way okay
it's not these past few years why would
they say that so much and
why would you eat this you want to
change the world
great love spiderman love insomniac
why would you even
why would you even start with that line
oh
the amount of people
i'm gonna go uh
who would have just i i want to watch
reaction videos to see how many people
lost their minds thinking that was
bloodborne just ask for help next time
time to bring back come on
why you know what you're doing who knows
jesus
happy about this in any case that's rad
the mods will be awesome that's super
cool great
but wow
wow wow what a choice of sentence
[Laughter]
oh god they really
just went for it what's this game called
stray i think it is
i believe so i'm gonna cut myself in a
little bit more
um
yeah i'm really sold on this game i
think it looks really neat i just hope
it's not very long like this is the kind
of game that i'd be happy to play for a
good full of five hours
you give me a ten hour um little puzzler
it might say it's welcome
i think it looks really really
endearing and i really like the look of
the world more than anything
kind of got some remember me vibes for
anybody who played that back when uh
dontnod made a very different kind of
video game
is this cat a cop
unclear he may be okay no
the drone is the cop
[Music]
no yeah the drones are the cops
confirmed cat not cop
[Music]
yeah i really really like the style it
looks gorgeous very very into it
just just a 100 percent going to play it
[Music]
never really stayed for that oh there
you go oh awesome sooner than i expected
that rules i look forward to it
explore a mysterious cyber city in stray
coming to ps5 and ps4 july 19th that
would have been a cool
up next three games that will get your
heart racing
[Music]
this looks pretty
let's get out of this
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
dead space vibes
especially with the health bar on the
back of his neck
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your new life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
oh my
[Music]
it's actually kind of making me think of
condemned a little which
yeah something about it i couldn't tell
you what it's making me think condemned
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time this has been
great so far
ultimately
yeah i've really enjoyed this so far
what is it what is it called
crafting
the kalista protocol
i'm definitely gonna play it
100 gonna play it
i love a horror game
let's go
in the year 2030 very different vibe
here
a new blood sport grips the globe
[Music]
and in the arena
there will only be the victorious
and they're dead stylish
whoa
i didn't expect that
[Music]
how does this work as multiplayer
assuming it is
[Music]
[Applause]
this looks really cool
like super stylish but also just like
actually fun to play should you really
use one book
the world is watching
hell yeah dude
that looks sick curious if it's
multiplayer or not i just assumed
sometimes
i wonder
near if things will ever be normal again
not near
that's quite an opening
i like to look at this
damn okay
little date up there like it's not
hopeless is that morgana does anyone
else get hurt
don't you want science in your corner
the date
makes me think of um
persona
oh you
i'm going to miss them
[Music]
it's a dating scene
[Music]
i mean okay that's basically like not
too dissimilar conceptually to persona
is this a persona game is this atlas
surely not
[Music]
eternity's okay it's not probably very
similar to persona which is like
dating stuff
school kid saving the world stuff which
i love persona
very new persona fan i've not played all
of them but i am
really enjoying and dating sims collide
in eternity coming to ps5 and ps4
interested i really like to learn more
let's check back in with capcom for a
new look at an upcoming heavy hitter
street fighter
street fighter
it's that heavy hit
it's pretty literal
capcom actually out here killing it
through this one i think they said it
was going to be 30 minutes we're already
20 minutes in
capcom putting him wow you go looking
for strength
it's not like a game
this journey doesn't have a real ending
can you imagine if we got dragons dogma
too okay then you're ready you just have
come to that
if you want to start off on the right
hit the streets
never feel loose and when i get up in
the game
a real problem but i solve them all face
proof and if you think
full context i'm not a big street
fighter person
i used to play but haven't in years and
years and years
not since uh
finally
yeah i actually have a lot of trouble
playing fighting games um i love soul
calibur i love bombas capcom 3
especially
i think i have a video on my channel
titled why i can't play fighting games
it's obama
that looks awesome
[Music]
[Music]
looks good
[Music]
a lot of
2023's out here
they coming
that was your first look at street
fighter 6 gameplay mark your calendars
it comes to ps5 and ps4 in 2023. what
what part of the calendar am i supposed
to mock just all he is it's time for two
adventures arriving later this year i
really like tunic i really really like
it oh it's already out on xbox
it's hot
i found tuning caught in the elden ring
unironically
i haven't finished it um it's like
immediate thing i want to go back to i
just the area i mean i got stuck
yeah i really like it
[Music]
[Applause]
i kind of want to stop watching this
this is showing me areas
i would see this and just stop watching
for cheating
[Music]
is it done
all right
yeah it's awesome stuck that that's
coming to to playstation won't people
play it it's very very cool really
really enjoyed it
need to finish it
some camera angles adjusted for trailer
use
and that's how picky we are about
trailers now we've got to clarify that i
set out to record life at the end of
this season this is pretty
to make it real for people in the future
she asked us about living together
and we asked her about traveling alone
interesting when the season turns
what will remain
[Music]
only what she saw
what she captured makes me wonder where
is valley of the gods in the valley of
the gods in the valley of god she
carries the sounds of the season with
her
what happened
[Music]
this is very pretty i'm interested in
the way she thrust made you want to tell
her everything
i got to look in her journal
the world was telling her secrets
i think once she even figured out
what will happen to us
when the season ends
this looks very pretty yeah is it going
[Music]
is it gone
[Music]
not yet
hmm
that looks gorgeous
seems like something i'm pretty lucky
yo yo
to see this always am
says in a world world by tyranny in
turmoil
who are we
what are the dominance
the power we wield
it wears away at our very being
it breaks us
it unmakes us
that its immaculate aspect might reveal
itself
the icon
the icon square enix isn't there
[Music]
every day we delay brings us closer to
disaster
that these captions are having a time
that looks
sick decidedly not turn based
i unite the dominance
that we may bring an end i wonder if
you'll also get um
part two in order to see us
it's
to its foundations
nine tails
this looks
especially epic
it's really pretty
there will be losses it is true
yet for every citizen who falls
another can be bred
for every home that burns another can be
built
the empire will live on
[Music]
that's still quite a good song i am into
that song
looks dope dude looks sick
very epic is the impression that i get
awaken child of fate
hello awaken
every
looks awesome
oh that's it and that's a wrap don't
forget to visit playstation blog to
learn even more about today's
announcements yeah i thought it was a
good one um i can't believe they did the
playstation fan favorite coming to pc
the way that they did it
i can't believe it
it's so wild
um
yeah i really enjoyed it actually more
than i expected i was expecting it to
have more of a focus on a psvr too for
some reason i don't know how i got that
in my head i must have read that on like
i don't know some news site somewhere um
but obviously
a lot more than that
that was rad what a great way to kind of
start off we had uh sonic and pokemon
yesterday and i really liked pokemon
didn't like sonic so much
this was great good way to kick off you
know a whole week of not e3 it's
technically e3 time jumping right into
it sorry that the channel is gonna have
so many reaction videos it is what it is
um it's my favorite time of year ladies
and gentlemen
let's do it